we like to play a quick roundup truth or
dare
[Music]
okay we have liz wessel here hi
the correct pronunciation
yes
so i have a truth for you both okay oh
if you were to swap bodies for one day
what is the very first thing you would
do when you woke up in the other's body
oh wow
oh i would be like wow
honest answer
leave it alone
what would you do
what oh nothing nothing like that
i can't help it if you woke up all of a
sudden as a man that would be the first
thing i would think to marvel at where
your brain goes is so funny right to the
potty yeah right um
well um you know gosh i wish i did wake
up in your body roth because here's what
would really happen yeah
um
i would be disciplined because sometimes
i am not really disciplined and you are
really disciplined with your food and
your diet and your wellness oh you'd be
you wouldn't eat a whole bowl of mac and
cheese
which is what she tries to get me to do
around here all the time i know no i
would be i would be excited that i you
have like you have strong willpower yeah
thank you well it's you know not
fantastic it's new it's new
um
if i woke up as drew barrymore i mean
i would want to like greenlight a new
charlie's angel movie and casa ross
matthews is bosley but i wouldn't do
that i wouldn't
i would do whatever i could to set you
up for the next day till you have a day
off with your daughters that's what i
would do because i know that's what my
friend drew loves more than anything in
the world i know i god russ what is
wrong with me well
all right i would all right let me if it
makes you feel better i would take a
peek i would
because i've never seen it really before
though
liz aren't you glad you asked i love it
thank you so much great question
[Music]